like if you if you reach the top of the
mountain but your spiritual health
your family like your physical your you
know your whole life's in total shampoo
is that really success we don't believe
so
so what does it take to dominate on
youtube what do you do when you
feel like giving up or you lack vision
for what the future can be like well i'm
excited because today's episode we're
going to be diving into
four key values that will help you not
only dominate on youtube
but create a lasting business that will
give you
legacy now in today's episode sean's
gonna be breaking down
four different values that you
definitely need to lean into make sure
you get your notebook ready
because these four values are from the
heart this is really a message
of how do you stay consistent but not
just consistently uploading
how do you stay consistent when you feel
like quitting my name is heather torres
and you're listening to the
think media podcast the number one
podcast
where we help you grow your influence
with youtube and then take that
influence and grow a high impact and
high profit
online business and we deliver a brand
new episode
every single tuesday so make sure you
subscribe
wherever you're listening to this
content on now today
i'm excited because we're diving into
impact that is a huge part of what we do
here at think
and it's really what makes us stand out
in the market that we're in
and i want you to be able to define what
is the impact
you want to make on your audience
shawn's gonna break down
four different values to have and how
those can help you to dominate on
youtube
alright let's get into the featured
[Music]
content
well hey welcome back to the think media
podcast i'm so fired up for this
particular episode where i'm actually
going to be sharing a session
that i shared during the pandemic
that really forced me to clarify some of
our values
some of our vision at think media it was
titled how to lead through crisis
and dominate the next decade and
there's really two big takeaways that i
know you're going to get out of this
podcast the first one
is in the past episode we talked about
the
best way to build a strong audience on
youtube not just your what not just your
how
but really your why sharing your core
values
and the second thing that i think you're
gonna get out of this is not just
seeing some of the core values that
drive think therefore driving the
results
and the numbers and the team unity and
some of the behind the scenes things
which is the point of this podcast
the second thing is actually potentially
getting some
pillars that i believe will be strength
to you for dominating the next decade
that's pretty lofty like you might be
like sean i'm just kind of exploring
youtube like what do you mean
i'm not even thinking 10 years ahead but
the way we
think here at think media is we think
big we think about the future we think
about legacy
and so these four core values i think
help us go beyond just trying to make
the next viral video
or go beyond just trying to get a few
subscribers or get a few views and to
make us
ask a deeper question about you know
what is it we're building over the long
haul and so i hope that out of this
episode
you can galvanize some of your own
values maybe benefit from what i believe
our key principles to helping you
dominate the next decade
and to capture a bigger vision for
yourself and your brand
okay so let's kick it off with these
four points and these are four
commitments that we have here at think
media that i believe have helped us
rise to the influence that we have in
the industry and will help you in your
own niche as well so this is how to
consistently
lead through crisis and dominate the
next decade number one
is a commitment to excellence a
commitment to excellence i believe if
you want to win on youtube you want to
win on business you want to win as an
author a speaker you want to win on a
podcast
i think you have to have a commitment to
excellence of course you could
at some point just be experimenting just
starting just testing things out
but eventually you got to commit to
excellence
when a new industry starts it's about
who's first
but once it matures it's about who's
best
that's just a fact of things so when
something new comes along
call it tick-tock or even like youtube
shorts you do have a chance to
have some influence if you don't
necessarily have if you will
excellence you're not the best you were
just first you got a lot of momentum but
eventually as an
industry matures it's about who's best
now this shouldn't make you feel
overwhelmed because you might be like ah
there's always someone better of course
there's always a better athlete always a
better youtuber always a better speaker
always a better marketer of course
there's always somebody better
but at some point you cannot compromise
on excellence and i just want to ask you
are you committed to excellence when it
comes to your youtube
channel are you committed to doing the
little things well
i think that that's a massive commitment
that we need not just to win today
but to have longevity over the next
decade and i learned this from brian
tracy and he said this
the most successful and ambitious people
see themselves as
capable of being the best they know that
the top twenty percent of salespeople
make eighty percent of the sales and
they are determined to be among
the top group and learn how to sell like
the best
perhaps the most important first step
you take in a field of selling
which is what he's referencing is just
selling you could apply this to youtube
is to make a commitment to excellence
the most
important first step is a commitment to
excellence
to make a commitment to being the best
in your field resolve today
that you're going to join the top 10 and
be the most successful in your industry
in terms of earnings so it's a
commitment to excellence you know i
heard omar el takori
on the think media team define
excellence is simply doing the best
with what you have so again this isn't
actually being like shoot there seems to
be such a
large chasm between me and the
competition but a commitment to
excellence means a commitment to getting
one percent better every day getting one
percent better with every upload
you know there's a japanese term called
kaizen that we talk about at think media
a lot which is our commitment
of continuous improvement and if you
want to dominate the next decade you
just got to be
constantly improving i know that
sometimes you might feel tired sometimes
you might feel overwhelmed and i hope
this podcast is valuable to you and
always helping you
sharpen the saw sharpen the axe get
better
wisdom helps you succeed it helps you go
faster by
little by little getting better at what
you do
but i encourage you it's not the hacks
or the short-term
tricks that build high-impact brands and
businesses
it's about a commitment to mastery and
excellence
and what brian tracy told us is it's
simply actually starting by just making
a commitment you know
i have committed to getting better at
running i'm not great at running
i just went running with gabe perez and
melissa caputo
from the think team and i've discovered
that they are a lot faster than me like
so they're they're more athletic they're
faster they have more endurance
but i'm committed to getting better so
it actually just reminded me oh shoot i
gotta train more
i gotta i gotta rest up more i gotta
recover better i'm gonna
run more hills i'm gonna actually run
out to red rock here in las vegas
and train on some of those trails
because my butt got kicked when we were
running up these trails
up a hill and i realized man i'm getting
winded pretty quick
i'm committed to excellence doesn't
matter where i am today but the
commitment is i
i want to get a little bit faster
tomorrow i want to get a little bit
better tomorrow
and so a couple questions i have for you
is what are you committed to being the
best in the world
at we'll link up in the show notes our
episode on
whether or not you should quit youtube
which was based off of seth godin's book
the dip
and he talked about at the end of the
day what you want to stick through the
dip
towards is what you're committed to
being the best at and remember
when we say best it reminds us of the
restaurant
in a small town that says the number one
best steak
in omaha dude i promise you that there's
32 restaurants that have that exact sign
in their window
but when you're in that town like they
are the number one best in that moment
in that world so you just want to be the
best in your world
the best kind of in your niche niche
niche your triple niche
deep you know the best and as you can
carve out your unique positioning
then that can actually help you be
excellent in a particular specific area
this will help you on youtube
so what are you committed to being the
best in the world at
it also is probably good to commit to
what are you committed to
not being the best in the world at you
may have been a part of our journey
of changing the branding of our think
marketing podcast to the think media
podcast
that was us refining our brand but on
that same journey
we committed to shifting a little bit
from being a
podcast in a video podcast that's about
all things online business and all
things social media
separate from youtube but we doubled
down and said
you know youtube is our thing and if you
separate youtube from the equation
sure we could talk about online business
but our best place to talk about it is
in the context of youtube
what am i trying to say that we're
committed to being the best
in the world at youtube and how to build
a business
around youtube and so a small pivot for
us here at think media was to kind of
pivot away
from trying to say we're the best in the
world at online business online
marketing and social media there's so
many others
in the sea of podcast options and video
options we just wanted to kind of find
our smaller niche within a niche
i learned this back when i wrote my book
youtube for churches
that all of a sudden i was afraid of
writing a book that was that specific i
wanted to write social media for
churches and i didn't even want to niche
down
for churches although that had been the
context i've been doing social media in
but when i did it boom i instantly
became the best in the world
at youtube for churches why because zero
other people in the world were even
talking about like there was nobody
like it was i was the only author with a
book on youtube for churches
i was the only person positioned to talk
about so you can really actually rise to
preeminence and if you will
excellence the more niched down you
get when it comes to clarifying what it
is you do on youtube
and in your business and in your overall
mission
but number one commitment to excellence
what are you committed to being the best
in the world at and what are you
committed to mastering
what helped me was for a while with
heather taurus and i especially even in
our inner circle program and things we
were going through we
still it's it's funny because it's a
small tweak we still talk
about all the social media platforms and
how they relate to youtube
but for a while it was even check this
out even our event growth video
in 2020 was called the number one
video marketing event for entrepreneurs
and business-minded content creators
we're refining our niche mastery we
flipped it
the number one youtube marketing
event for entrepreneurs a
business-minded content creator small
tweak but it was like listen
at the end of the day i know video on a
lot of platforms but like
there's so many dang platforms you want
to learn linkedin video talk to my
friend michaela alexis
you know you want to learn instagram
video talk to brock johnson and
learn reels and i like we want to go
even
deeper into our area of specialty which
actually helps
me helps our team say we're committed to
mastering youtube and listen those other
things matter so much but they're
actually through the lens
of youtube another resource for you is
don't miss the episode we did with rory
vaden and he talks about that
clarifying your brand your niche brand
your mastery point becomes the lenses
with which you see the world through
so of course we need to talk about email
marketing but we talk about it through
the lens of youtube
we got to talk about how to host your
website and different things like that
build your business online but it's
through the lens of youtube for us
we're committed to mastering youtube
what are you committed to mastering
what are you committed to being the best
in the world at jeff bezos said this
a brand for a company is like a
reputation for a persian
person you earn a reputation by trying
to do the hard things well
i'm not trying to say that a commitment
to excellence is easy but i am saying
that it's worth it
and so what are you committed to doing
the hard things well
in so that you can earn a reputation
in a particular area that'll help you
dominate the next decade
number two let's dominate the next
decade on youtube
by number two a commitment to wellness
now before you turn off the think media
podcast you might be saying sean
listen bro talk about the algorithm man
give me some tips on thumbnails
give me some tips on you know on on how
to
hack youtube views but i actually really
believe that this number two point
is one of the most important youtube
success principles
and just life and business principles in
general a commitment to wellness
i'm convinced steve jobs said this that
about half of what separates
the successful entrepreneurs from
non-successful entrepreneurs
is perseverance and here's the thing
friend you cannot persevere
if you burn out you cannot last
for think about three years from now as
you're building your youtube empire
think about six years from now as you're
building your youtube empire
if you don't have a foundation of
wellness and health
then you're not going to be able to
sustain a pace
of building your business brick by brick
moment by moment furthermore
you're not going to be able to be
growing in excellence
or coming up with your best content your
best titles your best
ideas your best thumbnails you're not
going to be able to be your best on
camera
if you don't have world-class energy i
know that this isn't the topic
of this podcast but it is the topic of
this podcast
because business is a game of attrition
youtube is a game of attrition you might
be slogging it away on youtube for four
years
and you might feel like you've only
gotten marginal success slow growth but
growth
but you haven't had your breakout moment
if you can sustain
and persevere through the hard
times through the valleys through the
obstacles
and you can just get to that other side
the majority of people will have given
up
but you'll still be standing and one of
the ways you'll be able to do that is
because of a commitment to
wellness here's a question for you what
habits
if changed would give you more mental
spiritual emotional and physical power
in your life and business
like what habit right now would give you
more mental mental clarity mental energy
ability to come up with good ideas your
next best content idea
spiritual energy maybe you're waking up
heavy
you're you're you're waking up like you
gotta wait on you of
anxiety a spiritual heaviness
emotional physical do you have enough
energy to accomplish
and create the content implement the
things in business
follow through on your promises create
the things you want to create i know
this is heavy
because i have to i when i put myself
through this there's habits i need to
change
but ask yourself that question because
this will help you dominate the next
decade
and last over the long haul i want you
to hear my heart think media podcast
we are committed to you winning like
that's what this podcast is about it's
helping you in
helping you reach your goals and in my
opinion
success is not just even just hitting a
successful youtube channel if you lose
your health in the process
i don't want you to build financial
freedom but lose
your health freedom because you've fried
your adrenal glands on the process from
all the stress it took to get where you
were trying to get
we want you to not just have short-term
success but long-term success
that's how you build real legacy and
that's impossible without a commitment
to wellness
another question for you what is your
biggest vulnerability personally and in
your business
what's your biggest vulnerability it's
like a question to identify your blind
spots before they become
a problem you start seeing
that man it's an evaluation that maybe
hey if i
stay at this pace
something's going to need to something's
eventually got to give
so i'm going to make decisions today
before it becomes a problem
you know when a check engine light comes
on in your car
it's telling you to just check the
engine it is not saying
your engine is exploding the pistons
froze up and there's flames coming out
of the engine at that point you would
not need a check engine light
the engine failed at that moment the
check
engine light is a warning ahead of time
to say hey why don't you just go get a
tune-up hey it might be time to change
the oil so that you don't
burn through this oil and seize up the
engine hey it might be some time to make
some tweaks
what's your biggest vulnerability listen
it might not even be a problem now
but if you think about it now and you're
smart now in terms of wellness
then you will be able to not just crush
it on youtube in the next 12 months
but over the next decade because of that
foundation
james altucher said this don't buy into
the 20 hours a day entrepreneur myth
you need to sleep eight hours if you
want to have a focus mine
you know sometimes i can get a
reputation people see i do rise and
grind on instagram every day
and uh to me rise and grind because as
much
as i believe in hustle and hard work i'm
like the biggest sleep guy you could
ever meet
like i obsess over getting enough sweet
sleep
quality sleep taking naps if needed
because i'm like if i don't have a
focused mind or the right energy
no good work is going to come out of me
so i think about
the power of sleep to me rise and grind
is rise and make coffee come on somebody
it's grind the beans
and of course it means also grind and
like be focused put in the work
but here our heart coming from think
media we are not about
hustle culture that's toxic we are about
balance and we believe in a strong
work ethic but also a strong rest ethic
and that longevity as an entrepreneur
and as a youtube creator
you need both and here's just the thing
of sleep listen to this when it comes to
sleep
first and foremost sleep deprivation
impairs attention and your working
memory
and it also affects other functions such
as long-term memory and decision making
partial sleep deprivation is found to
influence your attention
especially vigilance so
these are some of the benefits of
getting enough sleep don't buy into the
myth
that like i'm just grinding i gotta get
my youtube channel going i'm gonna
sleep one hour a day i'm gonna do this
thing no like you're going to be a lot
more effective
if you have a commitment to wellness but
this is just one area sleep
sleep increases fertility it wards our
heart disease it increases sex drive
it prevents diabetes it boosts mental
well-being
it can slim you and it boosts
immunity dude who if someone's telling
you shouldn't sleep
they're wrong like you need to figure
out whether you need seven
eight maybe nine hours a night and of
course there's gonna be those times when
you grind a little bit
but i consider that foundational what
habits if change for you would actually
help you be
more effective not just in the short
term but over the next
decade number three is a commitment to
service
commit to service number one is commit
to excellence number two is commit to
wellness number three is commit to
service
tony shea said this customer service
shouldn't just be a department
it should be an entire company yeah
yeah scott cook said this instead of
focusing on the competition
focus on the customer wow
you know on youtube it could be really
challenging
to just worry about what our competition
is doing
to just think that youtube is about
views
subscribers and oh look at how many
views the competition is getting how
many subscribers they have
but did you know that every one of those
subscribers is a person
like every single one of those
subscribers is a human
and and in a way they are your customer
because even if they're watching your
free content which you can monetize
through ads at a certain point
they're they're your viewer so what if
you focused
and obsessed over your viewer
and giving them great content
making deep connections with them
serving them
you know one of our core values at think
media is servant
leadership that the greatest leader
example that we have is jesus christ and
he said he didn't come to be
served but to serve and he said actually
the pursuit of greatness
is a great thing to pursue but the
greatest among you will be your servant
like
serve others so if you commit to service
and if you think man my youtube channel
is
in service of other people it's a whole
different perspective than most people's
approach to youtube
if you want to build a real legacy over
the next decade
and really build not just like a
powerful youtube channel but a powerful
movement and a powerful brand
commit to service maya angelou said it
this way i've learned that people will
forget what you said
they'll forget what you did forget what
you did
but they will never forget how you made
them feel
can you inject more love service
gratitude appreciation in your
content one of the things we do you know
we we get a lot of comments on think
media and i'll be honest we can't answer
all of them we get
hundreds and hundreds a day but we do
a couple times a week a thing called
love bombs on the think media team where
we block
time we'll hop on zoom we put up a
little countdown timer
and we we do as many comment replies
hearts back to comments
emojis deep answers we we stay anchored
in
we are here to serve our community it's
not some
just mathematical subscriber number
every
subscriber is a person every person
matters and to the best of our ability
and we make mistakes and i'm sure we
could do better
but the attitude that we are coming from
is an attitude of service
can you commit to service at a higher
level when it comes to the content
you're creating maybe this is a new
concept
you're like bro like i'm just making
like motherhood video i don't
i was just like trying to give some tips
yeah you're serving people
and the greater you weave in a heart of
service it could be so
so powerful our culture is more selfish
than ever before
so service stands out isn't it true have
you noticed that our culture is becoming
more and more selfish and self-absorbed
so when you serve others you're gonna
have
a remarkable result over time as your
youtube channel builds a reputation
for being committed to service and don't
ever think that this won't help you
achieve your goals and your ambitions
and your revenue targets
i think it was zig ziglar who said you
will get everything
in the world that you want if you just
help other people
get what they want it's just putting
others first
serving them and then realizing that
your income is directly
proportional to the amount of value you
add to the marketplace
serving others so define these questions
who are you committed to serving
powerful
so know you're who for me i am not
committed
to helping women get through menopause
you know what i mean like that's just
that's not
my gift of particularly how to to that i
can help people
i'm not committed to helping men get a
six six-pack abs
because i don't got them there's not a
lot of tips that i could pass along to
help them
your who helps you even know that person
you're called that person you're
uniquely wired to help and to serve
who are you committed to serving how
could you over deliver value to your
community and customers right now a
great question
how could you over deliver value to your
community and customers right now maybe
your early
stage and you don't even feel like your
business has taken shape yet
how can you just overly deliver value to
the one
comment that is showing up on your
videos to the two comments
how could you over deliver value to the
50 followers you have on instagram that
you can maybe follow them back or dm
them or go deeper with them
to just over deliver value to go out of
your way
today to serve
your community and then where are you
weak
and underserving your community right
now can you double down one of the
things
that i've noticed is that as youtubers
get bigger
they stop doing the things they did at
first
that got them to where they are it kind
of reminds me when you hear about like
taylor swift
you know showing up to people's weddings
face timing people
continuing to do she can't do it for her
millions of fans
but like andy stanley says do for one
what you wish you could do for all
for us i think media we fight to just
stay anchored
in that area of serving people and
trying to make those meaningful moments
um of really creating community and not
just creating content
and even as i talk about these things
like i feel that i'm like man i got to
step up i'm like i'm preaching to myself
i'm feeling this myself
how can i take this to another level
friend that's why this is just a
commitment
it's not that you're always doing it
well i know that i need all these areas
and this podcast is
as just as much for me as it is for you
i
want to recommit to wellness today i
want to recommit to excellence
today and number three i want to
recommit to service today
finally fourth one and i hope this is
serving you
it's going to be a good decade with
these commitments number four
is commit to mission commit to mission
what have you set as a powerful
long-term
vision mission and principles
for you your company or your youtube
channel
sean i have never even thought about it
well good i'm glad you're listening to
this podcast
like what is your have you set
a long-term vision how do you even do
that well maybe that's
that's actually a great idea we'll write
that down i'm thinking about that it'll
probably be a good podcast
how do you set a vision like you number
one you probably don't need to take
three months to do it but you might need
to take three hours you might need to
take a weekend
to really go deep in clarifying your
vision
have you set a mission for your youtube
like what's the mission of your youtube
channel
this will give you so much more clarity
so much more direction it'll help other
people know where you're going
and even principles like if you've
predefined your principles
then you know actually how to make
decisions a lot quicker when you come up
to wise in the road of which way to go
so it's a predetermination
of what your principles are your mission
is and your vision is and then it's
committing to that mission you know
our mission here at think media
is to help 10 000 purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference
in the world with youtube and
to help those people that reach full
time achieve that success
without losing their soul success
without losing your soul right
which kind of goes back to that wellness
like if you if you reach the top of the
mountain but your spiritual health
your family like your physical your you
know your whole life's in total shampoo
is that really success we don't believe
so and we believe that you can
achieve success on youtube without
losing your
soul that's a commitment to mission and
as we continue to talk about that
mission not just with you
but with our team we are doing things we
have what's called the three big rocks
in our company
and that's like every quarter we set
three big goals
and the three big rocks might be like we
know we have a certain promotion coming
up that'll be
marketing a product and that we want to
hit certain sales with
we have some maybe administrative stuff
like let's clean up some um
you know courses and some back end
things and our websites and pages and
some different things to do
these are our rocks for uh this past
quarter and then
our most current third big rock though
is acceleration of customer
success so it's also not just throwing a
mission out there it's commitment to the
mission
always asking how can we be do better at
helping our students and our customers
and in particular i mean you're watching
our podcast which is entirely free
we put out a lot of free content our
biggest death star laser
kind of a funny word life star laser is
on
our customers to say man those are the
ones we can serve at the highest levels
our video ranking academy students
and how do we help them reach that
target what else can we do you know when
you're trying to define and discern your
calling i've heard a couple tests you
can do
is what makes you sad what makes you cry
what moves you emotionally
what makes you mad what makes you
frustrated
about the world what makes you
frustrated with how a particular
group of people are hurting or suffering
what makes you
frustrated what annoys you you know
what's interesting
i started to discover my passion for
video
and tech and lighting by when i was a
director of communications at a church
and i was frustrated
and mad when the sound was weird when
the lighting was wrong
when somebody uh the timing of the cues
when somebody would come out and they
would start talking on the mic and the
sound guy wasn't paying attention he
didn't unmute the mic
when there was echo like some people
didn't even notice
the things that you notice that probably
is a good signal an indication
of your mission and of your vision
so what are you fighting for and maybe
if you pick up a bigger fight
and you define who your enemy is and you
define what you want to accomplish at a
deeper level
i believe you're going to have a greater
impact over the next
decade and then what is the deeper
purpose
that is driving your business friend i
really believe
that as you commit deeply to excellence
you commit deeply to wellness you commit
deeply to service
and you make a commitment to mission and
remember these are just commitments this
doesn't mean perfection
this doesn't mean that you're maybe not
even overwhelmed or intimidated
by the mountain of excellence in front
of you you go man i got a lot to learn
so do i
you might sit down with a blank page and
you go i have no clue what my mission is
for me i've been refining my mission and
trying to capture a bigger vision for 10
years
the mission today is not what it was 10
years ago 10 years ago i was like
can i get one person to view my video
you know that's like that was the
mission like can i
does this thing even work i just got on
camera then it was like can we even just
pay our bills with this can we even hit
basic targets
and accomplish you know providing for my
wife and fighting for my wife
and just our family now today the
mission's bigger and i'm like can i
provide and can we
actually fund a company of 13 people
that's doubling over the next
year you know what can we do at this
next level and then it was like would
just one person buy my course
and be able to go full time on youtube
and now it's like we're getting
all these testimonies and all these
stories and all these people
that are sharing the impact and the
transformation that's happened to them
through video ranking academy now
there's movement
now there's a momentum and so we
continue to commit to our vision and our
mission
but even the vision and mission gets
bigger over time
you don't even need to have the full
picture yet you won't have it yet
just start planning on paper just start
dreaming
just start connecting with a deeper
purpose and
thinking about man what could be
with my youtube channel what could i do
what can i accomplish
who could i impact how many lives could
i change
could i change just one person's life
could i help just one person
could i see one family change one
children's
life changed whatever your vision is
clarify
your long-term vision keep working on it
your long-term mission
and define your principles your
principles that you live by that you
want to grow your youtube channel by
and i really believe that over the next
decade right
that as you commit to excellence you
commit to wellness
you commit to service and you commit to
mission that this will make you
distinct in a sea of sameness on youtube
and a sea of selfishness on youtube that
when you come from the heart of service
and when you come from the
mission-driven purpose-driven
perspective
it'll help you build something that's a
lot bigger than
just youtube i hope these ideas served
you today
and i'm excited to hear your feedback
whether that's in the comments
or whether that's even leaving a review
on the podcast maybe this episode
stirred something in you i would love to
hear about that
on our apple itunes podcast
reviews area if you got something out of
today's podcast and i appreciate you
until next time keep crushing it
well coming out of that session i hope
you are on fire i hope you see the
vision of what you can create
using the power of youtube now here on
the podcast every single week we love to
read the different
reviews that you have so make sure you
rate and review this podcast
over on apple itunes that'll help us get
it in front of other creators just like
you
and today's review comes from darkaholic
darkaholic says everything this
coffeemaker brings to the table is pure
marketing and inspirational gold
after five years of building my
videography business
around marketing and entrepreneurial
world sean cannell is probably the only
online video marketing specialist
that stands out with his communication
skills knowledge bombs
and implementation strategies now
darkaholic right there you've just said
exactly what we want to bring to you in
our value
here at think media it's all about
helping you with the strategies
helping you implement and helping you
take action to punch fear in the face
and press record so i'm so grateful that
this podcast is bringing you value
well thank you so much for listening and
we will catch you on the next podcast
you